[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's south palo antonio espn national
correspondent covering the nfl
nfl matchup host and he joins us happy
new year
uh sal is it a happy new year in
philadelphia today
it is not it is definitely not i think
every everywhere i go every every every
radio station i listen to
my friends are texting me people have a
sour taste
in their mouth this morning after what
happened last night in south
philadelphia
if this wasn't on national tv last night
there's a national
uproar because the integrity of the game
and you know it doesn't sound like doug
peterson's telling the truth
but the fact it's a stand-alone game
everybody has an opinion on this if this
was a one o'clock game
would there be this much outrage well it
was on national tv
so uh i think there's justifiable
outrage
uh i personally do um
you know and i think there's sadness uh
at the same time
let me explain myself dan let me explain
myself
i know the sacrifices that the players
and the coaches
any team officials around the league
made this year and their families to put
on 256 football seat games in a regular
season
i know the sacrifices that my colleagues
at espn
and other communications companies and
reporters from all over
had to make i know the sacrifices me and
my family had to make
you know wearing a mask everywhere
everywhere you go
looking for an enemy that has no
perimeter
where everything is a possible threat
to your life and health all of the time
and i thought that the league and the
players association
did a magnificent job in the pandemic to
put on the 20
256 games and this was the last game
this was number 256
and it was supposed to be a celebration
of the ending of a regular season in a
pandemic
if you could do that and also of the
greatness
of ron rivera coming back from cancer
to win the division and the greatness of
the struggle of alex smith
the 17 leg surgeries hardly can walk
was gonna maybe lose his leg his career
perhaps perhaps his life
comes back and wins the game and instead
we're talking about this
and that's where the sadness part comes
in
so you know if i'm the end if i'm the
nfl
if i'm roger goodell i'm putting on my
kenosaw mountain landis pants on right
now
and i'm doing a forensic investigation
of what went down
you're being serious totally
two thousand percent what could the
punishment be
well that's a good question you know um
let's not jump to punishment yet let's
just find out what happened here
because if you're saying to me that you
were playing to win the game
well then really who's buying that
so you think doug peterson was lying
well was it it was a must lie situation
after the game so
well yeah i mean let's i'm not going to
go there i just want to know what
happened
i think people want to know i think
people have a right to know don't you
well i would have if you want to see
what you have in nate sutfeld
then start him don't bring him in with
you know you're down three points and
i mean you could have made this decision
on a tuesday or wednesday and say we
want to see what we have with him
not bring him in where if they're
throwing him into the fire in more ways
than one
at that stage of the game that's my
problem with it you want to play the guy
play the guy let the let the uh you know
washington team know nate sidfeld's
going to be the starter
but don't tell me he gives you a better
chance to win the game than jalen hurts
does
well there's no question about it i
agree with you you should have started
him if you wanted to play him this is
the first opportunity the young man's
had to play all year long
i actually went through the media guy
trying to find out if he had thrown a
pass up to this point
and he had not so i mean i i think it's
worth the time
of the league to find out what happened
you know what's weird though sal is we
we yell at the
jags if they try to win a game we
criticize the jets if they try to win a
game
and then we're critical of the eagles
who didn't really care about trying to
win the game like
yeah but i'm not i you didn't hear me or
i think people who are
you know i didn't i didn't criticize the
jets for going out there and beating the
rams
far far from it i didn't and i think
that people
who are interested in protecting the
integrity of the game
know that hermed was right hello
you play to win the game what should
eagle ownership do
well that's the big question right i
mean
uh that and that's why i think the
league needs to make a phone call
find out what happened here where where
where was this decision made and how was
it made because i think
you know the again the outrage is
justifiable but there's also an element
of sadness here
and i think everybody needs to just take
a step back and find out what happened
if it was done
with the full knowledge of the
organization
or did the head coach just make this
decision
to insert nate sutfeld and not pick the
field goal to tie the game oh i know
another
play calling well you know i i don't
think i don't think that
um what i'm saying is terribly
uh off-piste here i i think
um i think it's peop if you were in
philly this morning
and these are philadelphia eagles fans
people who support the team
people are outraged dan
i i didn't i didn't know that they would
be outright unless they felt embarrassed
or whatever that feeling is
because you improved your draft stock um
you don't like the giants you didn't
want the giants to make the pla like i
don't know how petty it gets
and you know i'm not involved in that
rivalry but it it feels like
it was mission accomplished by the
eagles organization last night
yeah i don't think anybody's taking that
deal okay
i don't think anybody's taking that deal
i haven't heard it publicly
i haven't heard it uh publicly stated or
uh at all zero i mean i've been i've
been listening all morning
and i've been getting texts from friends
and talking to people who are eagles
fans you gotta remember i i
was a reporter at the philadelphia
enquirer i came to philadelphia as a
reporter
uh i don't have any skin in the game i'm
not an eagles fan i'm not a giants fan
i'm not a washington football team fan
i'm just looking at this as okay what
happened here let's
find out what happened i think people
want to know
people deserve an explanation within
mutually exclusive of it was a
nationally televised game
mutually exclusive that it happened at
the end of the season where a lot of
people put their health and safety on
the line to complete the season
i think you just look at it from the
standpoint of was this decision made
really to win the game or
did did doug peterson turn himself into
sam hinky
i i think it's i i i i shouldn't laugh
but i
they're wrong how many games in the nba
72
so there's only 16. you know i mean
this this kind of stuff is not supposed
to happen in the national football
league we are we have
this i don't have to remind you we see
it all the time man there's
not millions but billions a year bet on
the nfl and it's now
big business that the nfl is part of no
you bring up all
these are valid points you and and the
nfl
knows that it has a problem and when
they go to 17 games
you're going to have more meaningless
games there's you know
like that yes absolutely if for no other
reason
than to send a message that this kind of
stuff
can't happen at the end of the year
because we are going to add another game
you have to do at least do due diligence
and find out
what happened here because you're trying
to protect
a lot of people and a lot of money
i'll leave you with this if you're a
team looking for a quarterback would you
trade for carson wentz
absolutely no matter what the price is
well obviously the price has to be right
and the circumstances have to be right
but if i'm front wright and i know
philip rivers is retiring and he's going
to go into the broadcast booth or
wherever
i'm trading for carson wentz he's your
best
option carson wentz
is a hard-working hard-nosed
tough football player does he have flaws
yes he's not joe montana
he's not johnny unitas he has some flaws
that can be fixed in coach duck
he's just turned 28
he's got probably 10 if he protects
himself and he's protected probably
properly
10 to 12 years to play in the current
nfl
he has a strong arm and
you know he needs to be coached up and
we all
need at some point then
in our lives a change of venue
we all need a fresh start it doesn't
matter what it is
not all of us can spend 25 years at espn
like me
hey happy new year
i love you guys thank you for reaching
out but you you have to
somewhat agree with me that this is not
done when it's not over there needs to
be a follow-up
somewhere along the line now doug
peterson and howie roseman are going to
speak on a zoom call
in about 11 minutes from the nova care
facility i'm interested to see what kind
of questions they get
and what kind of answers they have but
this is
this is something that's outraged people
who support the team
is what i'm trying to say to you i
appreciate you
uh joining us and uh and thank you uh
at this i think we're going to take a
vote is this the best segment we've had
so far 2021 2021 down no no no doubt
no doubt okay well congrats yes top
three for sure top
three segments so far
segment to top three i mean i if the
words didn't even come out as a big
man's mouth
and i was born to talk three i better
get off the phone
yes because we've been on the air for 80
minutes in 2021
don't screw it up don't don't pull a
doug peterson here all right
gotcha all right thank you sal that's uh
south palantonio on loan for the
mothership